We are continuing our series Vlad to Dad
and Vlad is here so now we are side by
side I love those Graphics Graphics so
good uh Vlad thank you very much for
being here we're going to walk you
through you're welcome it's only my job
it's your job it's your job but this is
the tough this is a tough talk today we
were talking money Talking Money uh
we're talking about budgeting for your
baby which is not an easy thing to do no
it's not uh because raising a child from
birth until the age of 17 will cost
parents almost 300 000 according to the
latest government data and that is
adjusted for inflation so it's been
going up and that does not include the
cost of college which almost doubles I
guess right look at that number is it
worth it I don't know CBS dude
he's signaling to his four children
already don't go to school grade school
is just fine CBS News business analyst
Julius here to uh tell us what parents
need to know uh where does Vlad need to
begin
where does the budget start from the
moment uh our baby arrives which is
January 29th here to the time that she
goes to college 300 000 that includes
what that seems like way too big a
number so let's break it back down okay
I even think that's a low number
yeah all right let me go back and look
at my bank account yeah it wasn't no 300
Grand so let's start with how much do
you spend right now because until we
figure that out we're not going to be
able to adjust your budget so everybody
watching who's thinking about having a
child there are some things that you
know you have to cut back on when the
kid comes right some of my friends who
have who are married or coupled and
don't have children they call it their
single life when they're spending and
living large right so you want to figure
out what are you spending now then we've
got to add in a lot of costs we have to
have the cost of actually having a child
we have to have the cost of things like
diapers and there are tons of resources
for this and clothing and a lot of those
things are going to continue for the
near term and then also the long term
but I think what's most important in
this process is to just get a grip today
then we can adjust for the future one of
the things that's interesting to me is
it feels as if and correct me if I'm
wrong that the majority of the costs
involved in raising children have to do
with education and medical expenses if
you're buying extra happy female when
you're at McDonald's that's not really
putting I don't know there are 365 days
in the year the amount of like drips and
drabs dollars that fall out of my pocket
like oh I forgot the water bottle we got
to buy one oh someone's hungry we don't
have snacks that accumulates
and they need clothes exactly yeah
unfortunately
yeah but I think the number one issue
that we need to address is child care
yeah because this is a cost that has
ballooned and it was always an expensive
uh line item before the pandemic since
the pandemic cost of child care average
and I'm telling you average ten thousand
dollars a year so think about the
average household in the United States
which earns about 67 thousand dollars
right ten thousand dollars for child
care so what do you need to do you need
to do a lot of research about what is
the cost of care in my area how can I
get babysitters should I be getting
Nanny should I be thinking about this
are there resources does my workplace
provide for child care a lot of
companies after the pandemic threw that
in is a benefit it's an amazing benefit
and what you can do is try to put
pre-tax dollars away to save for some of
those costs very important to do that
you get Uncle Sam's help and there are
also for many people who are at the
lower end of the earning income stream
many of those people are able to qualify
for credits so again I'm sorry to say
that you're doing a lot of research on
breathing and having babies you also
have to do research on what is available
in your area for helping you out with
these costs but is there a magic number
that you you could say to Vlad you know
on a yearly basis this is what you
should plan on for your baby well is
there such a number I think that it
really depends on your lifestyle right
because well he has a good lifestyle I
understand that I understand that but
for example as Tony said there are
certain fixed costs that are fixed I
mean you live in a house so hopefully
that's going to be fine but if you were
to add on say that ten thousand dollars
for child care average maybe inflated if
you're on one of the coasts or live in a
big city if you add on the cost of
diapers and formula and all those things
I think that you are looking probably at
somewhere around somewhere between again
fifteen to twenty thousand dollars a
year extra that you are not spending
right now that's a huge thing let me ask
you about college preparing for college
should you start saving now and how much
money you should have started saving
well wait a second before you get into
it
yes yes and because I'm going to presume
that you can start saving for college if
you have your emergency Reserve fund if
you've paid down your credit card debt
and if you are saving for your own
retirement unless you have that then
know you can't save for college if you
are going to save for college the 529
plan is the most robust way to save for
Education you put an after-tax Dollar in
but it grows without taxation when your
kid goes to school you pull it out no
tax due 529 plans to buy them directly
through the states try to avoid buying
them through Brokers or advisors it's
really cheap and efficient to do it I'm
glad I got so much free stuff you can
take off my hands
get the shower I know you don't want to
be the center of attention
long story short get another job